hi Dean zanic producer Get
[Music]
Low oh it's wonderful I mean this is a
culmination to a 10-year Journey trying
to get this made and no better place to
be than right where I grew up Santa
Monica
[Music]
Beach you know the awards are nice but
really it's just a lot of hard work to
tell a good story I mean this is the
icing on the cake but I I didn't plan on
being here it's it's a nice sort of
happen stance from a a film well made
and hopefully it just encourages other
people to to hang in there and believe
in the stories that they're trying to
[Music]
tell I I think it's wonderful just to
break new barriers and and um if the
traditional ones aren't working find new
ones uh to find your
[Music]
audience uh Black Swan I think just very
daring film making great performances
you know the production is insane I
loved it yeah
[Music]
thanks